le sage certains diront le vieux après
ce que nous avons entendu je vous
appellerai simplement à méditer sur la
fable de la fontaine le lièvre et la
tortue l aller un pas de sénateur
alors que le sénat n'existait pas
c'était la référence au sénat de rome où
les sénateurs étaient ceux qui
apportaient le rassemblement et la paix
dont le pas dans les trions c'était lent
alors que les légionnaires marcher d'un
pas rapide et bien je vous propose
d'être celui-là mais pas seul avec vous
tous chers laurent wauquiez monsieur le
premier ministre edouard balladur votre
présence est un symbole et nous y sommes
extrêmement sensibles
je voudrais saluer et remercier pour le
travail qu'ils font ensemble le travail
que nous faisons ensemble nos trois
présidents de groupes bien sûr christian
jacob qui préside ce groupe à
l'assemblée nationale bruno retailleau
qui est un exceptionnel président de
groupe au sénat et franck proust
celui qui préside les français dans le
cadre du ppe au parlement européen cher
annie genevard cher bernard accoyer avec
qui nous avons vu vécu quelques semaines
vivante
permettez moi de me tourner vers jean
leonetti rouges avaient préparé un texte
jean pour toile hier soir mais au fait
en écoutant j'ai retrouvé le gens avec
qui j'ai partagé la passion pour le
service public de la santé
j'ai retrouvé le gens avec qui j'ai
partagé des interrogations puis des
avancées sur les questions éthiques
j'ai retrouvé le jean qui fort de son
parcours assez exceptionnel aussi
imagine l'europe de demain et porte un
certain nombre de valeurs de référence
merci cher jean d'avoir accepté de
présider notre conseil national
alors en jeu ne dit qu'un mot car chacun
connaît ma liberté
bravo pour jeudi soir
et merci mes chers collègues
parlementaires
chers amis militants c'est toujours avec
un grand plaisir que je retrouve les
militants de notre mouvement
moi qui jusqu'il ya quelques semaines
présidé la 10e circonscription des
yvelines
vous voyez que dans les yvelines on a
des jeunes qui poussent à écrire pour
aller de l'avant et particulièrement
aujourd'hui ce premier conseil national
après les bouleversements parfois
déchirant qui ont marqué notre famille
notamment l'an dernier la solidité d'une
famille se mesure aussi à l'aune des
difficultés qu'elle rencontre et qu'elle
peut traverser ce conseil national est
la démonstration
je ne ressens profondément je suis là
depuis ce matin j'avais dix minutes de
retard gens mais j'étais là depuis ce
matin ce conseil national est la
démonstration de notre solidité et de
notre volonté de poursuivre sur la voie
que tant d'autres avant nous oprah c est
bien joli calme elle l'a rappelé dans
son dernière et images alors à tous je
vous dis merci merci d'avoir résisté
merci d'avoir tenu merci d'être nombreux
merci d'être prêt à relever le défi de
la reconstruction et du rassemblement
quant à moi je vous propose de nous
inscrire dans l'action
l'action qui avec nos collègues
sénateurs avec bruno nous a conduit à la
victoire aux élections sénatoriales au
mois de septembre dernier
l'action qui seule permettra de
reconstruire une opposition organisée
volontaires clair dans son projet pour
la france
un projet qui correspond à cette
certaine idée que nous nous faisons de
notre pays pour que celles ci soient
aussi en capacité de répondre cette
france aux défis de l'europe à laquelle
je crois et à ceux du monde où entre
extrémisme violent ce drame humain
migration il faut que nous continuions à
porter la parole du progrès et la parole
des valeurs universelles savez j'ai
beaucoup parcouru mon pays notre pays
ces derniers mois
convaincu que je suis que le pouls de la
france bat dans nos territoires tous nos
territoires et j'ai la sensation d'être
revenu avec deux cailloux dans la
chaussure
le premier caillou c'est vraiment le
sentiment de ce que j'écrivais à
françois hollande en 2015 qui lie à une
france à côté oui à côté celle qui ne se
sent plus dans le jeu et nous l'avons
entendu ce matin dans l'intervention des
membres du conseil national
cette france qui se sent à l'écart tant
de territoires urbains ruraux de bourse
entre deux petites villes tant de nos
compatriotes ont le sentiment qu'ils ne
comptent plus en fait ils comptent les
rideaux fermés des commerces des centres
bourgs et des centres villes
eux ils attendent parfois elle ça n'est
pas anecdotique
encore un réseau de téléphones portables
convenable eux et autour de certaines
métropoles même ils sont sans transport
collectif où ils n'osent plus les
utiliser pour des raisons de sécurité
oui ils ont le sentiment d'être mis
définitivement à côté et que décidément
le pouvoir les décisions ne s'intéresse
plus qu'à quelques régions où à quelques
métropoles puissantes comme interrogé
récemment un élu rural du pas de calais
mon second cailloux et ils ne concernent
tous c'est l'état de défiance qui s'est
installé entre le pouvoir et les
citoyens entre les citoyens et leurs
élus
une grande nation ne peut admettre que
certains de ses territoires se sentent
abandonnés une grande démocratie ne peut
accepter cette fracture entre citoyens
et parlementaires
un pays comme le nôtre doit être
attentif à l'exercice des
responsabilités régaliennes par l'état
et aujourd'hui je vous le dis le
régalien est à la peine l'exemple actuel
des crispations de l'administration
pénitentiaire et l'état de nos prisons
en est un symptôme il y a le malaise des
forces de l'ordre il y à l'inquiétude
dans le service public hospitalier
il y à la recentralisation rampante d'un
gouvernement qui marque sa défiance
permanente entre les pouvoirs et les
élus territoriaux
il y a ce signal incroyable d'
abdication de l'autorité de l'état dans
sa décision sur le projet de notre dame
des landes
oui
oui notre tâche est immense et ses défis
nous devons les relever nous allons
débattre en cette année du 60e
anniversaire de la constitution de la
vème république de la réforme
constitutionnelle et institutionnelle
que propose le président de la
république
je suis pour ma part toujours réservé
quand on nous propose de toucher à la
constitution
clé de voûte de l'oeuvre du général de
gaulle pour notre pays
[Applaudissements]
et si je suis réservé ce n'est pas par
cas je ne sais quel conservatrice mais
tout simplement parce que cette
constitution nous a permis de traverser
bien des crises et deux cohabitations
elle a assuré au gré des alternances la
stabilité politique indispensable à la
conduite du pays
je mesure la responsabilité qui va être
celle du sénat des sénateurs
donc la mienne dans ce débat qui ne peut
pas être un marché de dupes où un coup
politique mais un débat de fond sur ce
qui peut permettre de contribuer à
renouer cette confiance citoyens élus
territoire si c'est une révision pour
mieux faire la loi
la faire mieux comprendre à nos
concitoyens une révision pour renouer ce
lien citoyen et lui une révision pour
mieux contrôler le gouvernement
mieux faire fonctionner certaines
institutions
alors oui par delà les clivages
partisans
nous pourrions en être si l' équilibre
des pouvoirs et si l' équilibre des
territoires sont respectées ce débat
ce n'est pas seulement un débat entre
577 députés 348 sénateurs
le président de la république le
gouvernement
c'est un débat qui concerne notre pays
le temps du dialogue je l'espère va
s'ouvrir au sénat nous y sommes prêts
dans l'esprit de ce contre pouvoir que
nous incarnons et qui a pour boussole
l'intérêt de la france
oui oui mes chers amis mes chers amis je
suis là avec ma sensibilité attentifs au
respect de la diversité de notre
mouvement je suis militant des
républicains est naturellement je le
demeure parmi vous
mes chers amis comment imaginer une
opposition qui ne serait incarné que par
la france insoumise où le front national
je suis trop attaché aux valeurs qui
fondent notre pacte républicain pour
l'accepter aucune république aucune
démocratie ne peut exister sans un
contre-pouvoir à l'exécutif et à sa
majorité
naturellement aligné à l'assemblée
nationale l'instauration du quinquennat
a d'ailleurs renforcé le fait
majoritaire
et si la seule voie institutionnelle
différentes c'est l'assemblée que j'ai
l'honneur de présider donc le sénat
qu'il incarne
car il ne dépend pas d'élection
présidentielle nous avons tout autant
besoin cher christian mes chers
collègues députés de notre groupe à
l'assemblée nationale nous avons besoin
nos parlementaires européens
nous avons besoin de tous nos élus
territoriaux nous avons besoin de tous
nos militants alors les républicains
c'est à partir de cet instant on dépasse
nos querelles
on respecte nos différences elles sont
légitimes
on s'ouvre sur les autres sensibilités
et formation dans les valeurs de
démocratie et d'humanistes sont proches
des nôtres
oui on s'engage dans le débat d'idées
mais nous partons pas de rien cher
bernard accoyer le débat il est
vivifiant il est enrichissant il ne doit
jamais être déchirure alors les
républicains on y va tous ensemble tous
ensemble on se met à la tâche pour que
vivent les républicains vive la
république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]